ich bin frisch dumbledore back from
beyond borders war das mikrofon mein
name ist luca herzlich willkommen hier
heute meine damen und herren zu einem
video auf dass ich seit jahren warte
dass ich jetzt aufnehmen kann und zwar
habe ich mir dieses ding bestellt das
ist eine virtual reality brille und wenn
man sich diese virtual reality brille
auf den kopf setzt ist einem relativ
schnell ziemlich schwindelig wir bereits
im titel gelesen habt schmidt mit dieser
brille heute minecraft dass sie ziemlich
beschissene grad alles aus ich war
bisher nur in diesem minecraft menü hier
drin wenn wir uns umdrehen wenn wir
schon das hier ist ein pilz weiter als
hierhin bin ich noch nicht gekommen bzw
wollte ich noch nicht gehen weil ich
meine erste erfahrung mit euch zusammen
herausfinden wollte das heißt meine
damen ich würde sagen wir klicken jetzt
einfach mal hier auf einzelspieler und
ach so geht das jetzt müssen wir uns
hier erst mal eine welt erstellen haben
das heißt ich dich und auch neue welt
erstellen spielmodus überleben ja bla
bla bla neue welt erstellen und jetzt
sie können später auch breitbart
er hat leute mir so unfassbar schlecht
ist dass mein mikro hallo also ja
freunde wir befinden uns hier in
minecraft hallo nase wir befinden uns
jetzt hier in minecraft da vorne geht
die sonne auf
ich kann mich noch umdrehen akku
ich hab ich dann gut mir ziemlich
schnell ziemlich schlecht und ich bin
rausgegangen und musste mich halb
übergeben
das ist nichts für schwache nerven mir
wird bei uns selbst schwer immer sehr
schlecht
allerdings würde ich sagen meine lieben
freunde stoßen wie die wieder zurück in
minecraft kann ich kann laufen okay wenn
ihm freund ich kann auf jeden fall
aufwendig natürlich kann ich laufen
das ist in meinem leben
münchen ich muss mich ja erstmal ein
bisschen zurecht finden gerade ich kann
auf jeden fall springen ich kann mich
umschauen wenn ich nach hinten laufen
will wusste ich mich umdrehen
das ist bei euch mögen ton jetzt
natürlich super allerdings meine lieben
freunde würde ich sagen dass wir uns
jetzt einfach machen
bei dir ich würde sagen wir laufen jetzt
einfach mal ein bisschen rum und
besorgen uns das erste was man sich
besorgen muss wenn man minecraft spielt
um zwar besorgen wir es uns wir brauchen
natürlich holz das ist der essentiell
wichtigste gegenstand in minecraft er
mit holz können wir uns nix machen wir
können uns sachen bauen wir können uns
gegenstände greifen und das ist nicht
wahr ich muss jetzt ich muss jetzt so
hoch gucken nicht an meinen rücken ich
dachte wie er wird spaß machen aber ich
habe jetzt nur schmerzen empfunden ich
war radwegen meinem magen schon direkt
auf'm klo ich habe jetzt gerade übel zu
rückenschmerzen weil ich hier wie so ein
gescheiter vollidiot stehen muss und
muss eine decke gucken
ich könnte kotzen allerdings haben jetzt
erst mal genug holz von diesem baum uns
gegönnt
das heißt ich gehe jetzt mal ein
inventar dass das mikro jener der
inventar knopf ist glaube ich der hier
genau da haben wir das inventar kann ich
jetzt mal hier die teile vom neben packt
jetzt mal so rein das ist das geht so
und dann so xalter mein magen 30 grad
schon wieder komplett um nun kann ich ja
einfach mal durch meinen inventar durch
scrollen und gehe hier auf die werkbank
an die werkbank hier platzieren
das nicht wahr hüpfen und auswählen ist
der gleiche knopf wer hat denn diese
scheiße programmiert na gut der
programmierer als hingekriegt minecraft
in virtual reality zu entwickeln und was
habe ich bisher leben geschafft nichts
aber gut freunde wir brauchen auf jeden
fall erstmal einen eine spitzhacke denn
mit der spitzhacke können wir uns können
wir können nicht kann ich mal
ich würde ich genau kann ich mir
theoretisch das ding einfach mal so
gegen den kopf
nee
okay der bericht vorher ab aber hey
ruder
das ja das ist schon das ist eine krasse
technik sorry dass ich hier die ganze
zeit irgendwie durch mein zimmer
rumlaufe aber wegen diesem ding muss ich
mich halt von umgucken
deswegen weiß ich nie wo das mikrofon
ist ich hoffe dass kein problem für euch
wir müssen uns jetzt auf jeden fall
erstmal weiter gedanken machen wie wir
die nacht überleben wollen die sonne ist
auf dem weg unter zu gehen ich würde
sagen wir würden uns erstmals einen
kleinen weg nach unten
wir haben ja eine spitzhacke das heißt
wir können uns jetzt hier ein bisschen
steine holen steine sind ja sehr sehr
sehr sehr wichtig in minecraft mit
steinen kann man sich viele weitere
gegenstände machen
tut mir leid dass ich jetzt
zwischendurch mal von der cam wegdrehen
ich habe jetzt erst mal einen ofen
gemacht haben das heißt die patienten
jetzt direkt hier neben genau jetzt kann
ich mich auf den ofen zu greifen jetzt
schauen wir ein bisschen heller hier der
ofen produziert jetzt holzkohle für uns
die können wir uns jetzt hier raus
nehmen können das ist wieder verlassen
können hierauf zugreifen nehmen jetzt
einen stock packen da drauf die
holzkohle und wir bekommen vier fällen
das heißt der mittel in der hand um mit
der fackel können wir leuchten das
erklären sich einiges
wir müssen uns auf jeden fall ein
schwert machen freunde
das heißt ich greife wieder hier auf zu
wir nehmen jetzt einen stock den wir
haben und dann haben wir hier noch
bruchstein glaube ich den neuen
kommerziellen partner personen schwert
das heißt ich kann jetzt kämpfen dass
meine fakt dass mein schwert ach so ich
kann da
wenn ich da unsere mission ist es auf
jeden fall die nacht hier einfach zu
überleben
das problem ist dass wir natürlich keine
1234 monster das problem ist dafür keine
schafe gefunden haben und uns
dementsprechend keine kein bett machen
können das heißt wir müssen jetzt
natürlich die nacht hier durchkämpfen
und irgendwie durch die naschen gesagt
okay haben was ja erst mal egal ob
jedoch weg machen so respektvoll sagen
sagte schweer
ich werde es nutzen
genau okay so coach
ich bin total fertig ich habe einfach
nur keinen bock dass ich jetzt wieder
sterben wenn ich einfach auf dem weg bin
zu meiner scheiß werkbank und meinem
ofen sorgen auch hier bin ich angekommen
wo sie meine sachen hier sind meine
sachen genau da sind
[Musik]
wollt ihr mich alle verarschen lassen
jeder merkt ja was soll ich jetzt machen
ich werde jetzt einfach mal auf optionen
gehen und die schwierigkeit auf
friedlich stellen weil noch steht ihr
seht schon nach vorne der creeper die
müssen jetzt alle verschwinden genau das
ding ist ich will einfach nur diese
erste nacht überleben und es ist in
viareggio gott verdammt schwierig mir
ist auch schon wieder so schlecht
problem ist auch ich weiß nicht wie man
schneller läuft ich weiß nicht wie man
ja ich kenne mich halt überhaupt nicht
aus mit denen mit denen irgendwie mit
denen die macht alle gehirnzellen gerade
schrott ich weiß nicht mehr wo das mikro
ist da hallo ich könnte kotzen wenn ich
das hier spiele alltag ein scheiß ich
dachte wie armut so richtig spaß machen
aber das einzige was davon haben es mit
geradem rücken schmerzen schmerzen und
herzschmerz weil ich hier nur im sterben
bin ich bescheuert oder wurst jetzt hat
wo ist mein schwer wissen dass das ding
ist ja dass wir jetzt die zombies und
monster und allgemein alles zu hause
haben ja eh die zombies streep als
klettert er ausgestellt das heißt hier
sollte uns eigentlich passieren
hier ist love war also das sieht ja echt
crazy aus interessant alles hier was das
eigentlich fünf etappen der schwede
anders ein stück scheiße in der luft sie
können ja auf dem weg noch ein paar
blumen mitnehmen ich meine gestern war
muttertag eigentlich wollte ich das
video hier auch gestern schon hochladen
aber ich habe wirklich stunden denn
gebraucht und diese scheiße hier zu
installieren also wirklich falls ihr
euch jemals oculus trifft kaufen solltet
ihr da seid ihr euch jemals riff kaufen
sollte
und ihr wollt minecraft wieder spielen
stellt euch auf jeden fall darauf ein
dass ihr stunden brauchen werdet um das
ganze zu alter mir richtig schwindelig
wenn du auch warum diese scheiße hier 1
jetzt bin ich tot wolfsegg in slate
das mikro die sonne geht auf jeden fall
auf meine lieben freunde das heißt wir
strecken unsere schwerter zum horizont
und winken dalai lama zu ende geht auf
jeden fall die sonne gerade auf er
hinter uns befindet sich unser toller
das ist jetzt schwer
man muss schon real talk sagen dass
minecraft echt ein sehr sehr schönes
spiel das ich weiß es wird immer so
abgestempelt als kinderspiel und so
weiter und so fort und es ist ja alles
nicht das allergrößte anspruchsvollste
spiele das ganze in virtual reality man
hier zu spielen ist wirklich ein hammer
mäßige erfahrung
ich bin
auf jeden fall hier zurück zu hause
angekommen beim einer werkbank das ist
immer noch mein schwert hier ich habe
jetzt eine halbe stunde minecraft
virtual reality gespielt und das hier
ist das was ich hingekriegt habe ja da
kann man wirklich mal klatschen
anders stellt ihr euch das heute gewiss
auch beenden meine lieben freunde mir
ist gerade ziemlich schwindelig ich
hoffe dass euch dieses minecraft in
virtual reality video hier gefallen hat
wenn es das getan hat dann lasst bitte
einen daumen hoch unter diesem video
jeder schaffen wir 50.000 daumen hoch
wenn ihr das schafft alter das zeigt man
einfach aber ich habe es gefallen ihr
habt da bock drauf und ich soll das
eventuell nochmal bringen schreiben auf
jeden fall tipps und in die kommentare
und vielleicht noch was sich eventuell
in einer nächsten folge minecraft
virtual reality machen soll oder ob ich
ein anderes spiel mal im virtual reality
spielen sollte mein gott horror spiele
alter ich könnte heulen auf jeden fall
will ich das video an der stelle jetzt
auch beenden abonniert man den kanal
falls noch kein teil der lupo seit und
jetzt kommt das auto und ich jetzt
kotzen
[Musik]